[music]
We're going to do things a bit different
this time. First of all, we're not going
to sit. Second, I'm going to speak very
loud so everyone will hear. And third,
I'm going to start with telling you
about a near-death experience I had uh
almost 20 years ago. Before that, I'm
Orcher. I'm the CEO of Bright Data. And
together with me in a few minutes on
stage, Dr. Sarah Kuber will join. Now,
while I'm talking about my near-death
experience, and you'll understand why
I'm doing that in a few minutes, I want
you to think about your own that thing
that might happen to you in the past
that every time you're telling that
story, you get the goosebumps. To me, it
all started in 2009
when I uh started I I went to fulfill my
childhood um dream, which is surfing the
east coast of Australia as an avid
surfer for many years. And I bought a
camper van and I drove through the
Australian coast and I surfed in every
spot I could find until I got to the
Gold Coast and I kind of stuck there.
Sorry.
And I kind of stuck there for a few good
weeks. And one day I misread the ocean
and I went into into a surfing session
and the waves were way too high for me.
And after like 30 minutes of surfing. I
uh I I realized I made a mistake and a
huge set of huge waves just came in my
way, pounding me over and over again
until it broke my leash, took away my
board and I was just left out there in
the ocean. And I started swimming to the
beach just to, you know, try to get
there safely. And it felt like eternity.
And I swam and I swam and I left all of
the energy in my body. And I remember
that experience that I felt completely
helpless, nothing I can do about it. I
felt that I have no energy left in my
body. And the worst experience I had is
kind of even an acceptance that I'm
might going to take the last breath in
my life. And while I swam to just take
that last breath, in the corn corner of
my eye, I saw my board all of a sudden.
So, I gave it a few less strokes and I
was able to get to the board and I
drifted to the beach and I survived. And
this still gives me the goosebumps when
I'm telling it almost 20 years after.
But let's park that fun story for a
second and get uh starting to talk about
robots.
So, to know the world, robots needs to
see the world and to to operate in the
world, they need to understand it. And
that's actually a solved problem if you
think about it because seeing the world
basically what we're doing right now is
becoming easier every day. I'm being
recorded talking to you. This will be
live in the internet in a few hours
time. And this is public information,
public content, visual content that
robots can train on. If they want to
walk in an event in Paris in two years
from now, they can get this data. And
this data is available for everyone. And
many of the people here are already
doing that and training the robots on
publicly available information as the
data provider for most of the robotics
companies at Bright Data, the visual
data provider. Talking about videos, 3D
imagery, images, everything that has
pixels in it. This is growth we haven't
seen in the entire lifetime of the
company. We're talking about thousands
and thousands of pabytes of visual data
being collected from the open web and
distributed to many of the companies
that are uh presenting here in the
Mckina event.
So with this data robots can as you know
understand spatial awareness really
well.
They can grasp depth and distance to
make sure they are walking here and uh
not bouncing into anyone.
They can understand which product they
need to choose if this is the test they
were given
and they can experience dexterity in a
very accurate manner and a lot more a
lot more than that.
The thing is that in a few years time
maybe less than that they will be all
around us. They will live with us. They
will work with us. They will serve us
247.
And they will also absorb a lot of new
context that they couldn't train on. How
can you train a robot on everything that
is happening in the world if the world
keeps on changing? Think of two
humanoids going out from the same
factory in the same batch, trained on
the same data, grounded on the same
data. One is being shipped here to Paris
to serve a family in in a Paris home.
The other one is being shipped to
Minnesota to an elderly house to help
the staff there. There's a reunion of
these two humanoids after a year. How
they will react to the same scenario?
How they will react to different
scenarios if the context they absorbed
over this year is completely different.
We can actually
um imagine how this will be or how
frustrating it can get because we're
working with robots all day long, right?
We're working with these virtual AI
agents all day long every day. And you
know the feeling that once you started
working with them, it's like magic. But
actually after a while when you have
like you know mutual history together
working you and your agent and you're
adding more and more context over time
to the agent and you're giving it more
and more tasks then it's starting to
lose focus sometimes on simple tasks
that a week ago it was perfectly fine
with and it's starting to drift
sometimes and you're experiencing what's
called context rot but this is all
virtual. what will happen with these AI
machines will have arms and legs and
they will live with us in our homes.
When I started thinking about that, I
thought that there might be a solution
to it from the data side of things which
we're um experts in, but I couldn't
fully realize how these humanoids are
going to experience the world on the
human level. And the only person I uh
had in my mind to ask is an expert in
what we call lived experiences. And I
called my dear friend Sarah. And the
first conversation was both funny, fun
and absolutely terrifying. And we kept
talking about that and I told her that
we need to do it on stage. So everyone
please welcome Dr. Sarah Kuboric.
[applause]
>> Hello.
This is really fun as an existentialist
to be at an AI conference.
So,
a lot of people come to me concerned
about the progression of AI because if
it can do a lot of the things we can do
such as neural processing and adapt to
context and much more, what makes us
uniquely human? Are we at some kind of
risk? And what I find fascinating is
that currently the conversation has done
two things. One is that we have
humanized AI really rapidly and even the
way we talk about it has become human in
its essence and at the same time we have
dehumanized humans. What I mean by that,
we keep talking about the human function
of like stimuli and response. Amazing.
Um, what is the function of a human?
What is the brain of the human? And we
are kind of forgetting about the mind,
the essence, the spirit of the human,
which does differentiate us just a
little bit from the current progression
of AI.
I love or story. He jumped on a Zoom
call and was like, "Let me tell you
about a time I almost died." He's like,
"Cool. Okay." Um, and what I loved about
it is because let's pretend that there
is a humanoid in the ocean and there is
ore in the ocean. Both are experiencing
the same context. That's what we would
want to say. But the reality is that
they are both in the same context.
They're not experiencing the same
context. And I think that that's a
really important distinction. I think we
have become a little sloppy with the
vocabulary that we have used which has
then confused the field and has also
alarmed a lot of individuals.
Why do we do this? There is nothing
scarier for the human mind than the
unknown. This is why we fill in the
blanks a lot about a lot of things. And
what we do is we often attribute human
characteristics and behaviors to uh gods
to objects sometimes to dogs. And we do
these things because it helps us deal
with the unknown. And we have now
essentially done the same thing with AI.
So what do I mean when I say this? So
language that implies things that aren't
actually there.
Okay.
AI understands, known, believes
something when it's pattern matching on
tokens. It decides when it's producing
probabilistic likely outcomes. That was
a mouthful.
Now we get into like the fun ones. AI
hallucinates it, but it actually
generates plausibly sounding but
inaccurate text with no perceptual
experience to distort. AI can't smell,
hear, taste, see, or feel things.
Therefore, he can't actually hallucinate
in the way that we have used this word
in psychology and psychiatry.
It gets confused when he actually just
produces incoherent outputs, not a
mental state. It tries to do something,
but there's no effort or intention. It
refuses. I love it when he says, "No,
Sarah, I can't do that for you." It
generates a token sequence that
declines. It's not an act of will.
and it lies. It produces inaccurate
outputs without knowing that they're
false. So, is it a lie if it doesn't
know that it's false? And lastly, I like
it when AI apologizes to me. But it's
not an apology. The word appears in
output, but there's no remorse. These
are really important distinctions. It's
like looking at a picture of a fire. It
might be beautiful. It might be
accurate, but it will never burn you.
Therefore, it is not inherently fire.
So, AI can know about things, but it
can't actually experience things. And I
think that this is what makes us
irreplaceable as human beings. I think
it's interesting that AI can produce the
word grief or it can process and learn
about grief, but it cannot grieve. It
can look at me and go, she's on stage
here. her mannerisms. Here's her voice
pattern. Here's what she's saying. And
yet, it does not know what it's like to
be me on this stage.
AI can know about things, but it can't
experience things. And the one big
distinction is the lived experience
involves the felt sense of being in your
body in time in relationship. I don't
know if you've ever experienced walking
into a room and knowing something was
wrong with zero proof that something was
wrong and then you'll find out something
was wrong. I think this is really
incredibly important.
And why it's important is that we need
to understand
we are much more than just biology.
So I'm going to teach you about
phenomenology,
something that philosophers have played
with for a really long time. It's a
study of structures of consciousness as
experienced from the first person point
of view. So instead of saying what has
happened to this person, it's saying
what is it like to be this person?
Instead of asking the question of what
causes us to see the color red, which by
the way is neuroscience, it's saying
what is the nature of experiencing the
color red? That's phenomenology.
I love phenomenology because it's
inherently human and it's not just about
sharing information. Um I think
phenomenology teaches us that change is
possible with encounter but change is
not experience.
What I mean by this is that a rock can
be changed by water. It can change its
shape because of the water pressure but
it doesn't mean the rock has actually
experienced the water. These are two
very different processes.
Marlo Ponti uh famous French philosopher
talked about embodiment and the fact
that it's not just mental. The human
experience is not just mental, it is
also physical and that's very different
than just having sensors. It is very
different to know what fear is versus to
experience fear being in the ocean. I
also think it's really important to
understand that you can have a flight
simulator
show you what turbulence is like, but
the pilot's not going to be scared
because the experience is absent.
So let's briefly talk about four
existential givens.
This is according to Irvin Yellum who is
a existential psychiatrist. He talks
about these four things making humans
different and without experiencing these
things there is no human experience. So
one of them is death. The tension
between the wish to continue existing
and the fact that we're one day not
going to exist. The freedom, the fact
that there is so much freedom in this
world to shape who we are in our
experiences and it's up to us to figure
out what those are going to be.
Existential isolation. the fact that no
matter how deeply someone wants to get
to know you, your spouse, your friend,
they're never going to fully understand
what it's like to be you. And that's
incredibly isolating and
meaninglessness. The fact that this
world is arbitrary and potentially
um absurd and that it's our job to find
meaning within it. The argument is that
without AI having to experience these
things, they're going to show up in the
world a lot different. Your nervous
system is not just impacted by the
world, he also has stakes in it. And
that's the difference.
The machine is exempt from all four as I
said and not because it transcends them,
but because it was never inside the
human experience to begin with. The
absence is not neutral. It is the
fundamental difference.
So the process is not enough
and I think it's important to know that
if it cannot be in it, what impact can
it have within it? I think that AI can
be incredibly useful without trying to
be human. I think that the danger is not
that it's going to replace us, but that
the humans are going to forget what
makes them irreplaceable.
I think that the speed and the pattern
recognition is not the problem. It's the
problem is when we forget that the human
capacity is more than that. It's about
suffering. It's about love. It's about
meaning something to someone else. And I
think that we can live alongside AI as
long as we're very cleareyed about what
the distinction is. So if AI can't
experience, what can it do?
>> I'll answer that.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> Thank you, Sarah. So the team at Bright
Data has been working in the last few
months on a very unique solution future
looking not as a way to
create experiences in robots to Sarah's
point but in a way to keep the robots as
close as possible to knowing like a
person
and we've taken a lot of the public
information that we've been collecting
over so many years and process that into
a visual database a very unique visual
database that you can just prompt and
search. In this examples, a person is
looking for scenes for visual scenes of
someone washing the dishes. And thanks
to this new product that we're about to
launch, the video search index and video
search API, you can actually find the
scenes that you need in order to get
that machine, the brain of the machine
that you're building closer to knowing
what it is to become a human, probably
without actually having those human
experiences.
And you can get that with the exact
timestamp of the scene that you need
perfectly aligned with the prompt that
you've added. download it through our um
bright data infrastructure and I believe
that this will be a crucial part of the
reinforcement learning processes that
these humanoids will need to go through
every single time that they're getting
new context they haven't been trained on
when I'm showing that to lots of people
everyone are talk saying yeah okay it's
like the Matrix when Neo got plugged
into the machine and all of a sudden he
knows kung fu so we switch Neo with this
humanoid but this is exactly what we're
talking about think about a humanoid
that needs to do something it wasn't
trained on. He will be immediately
connected to a fast connection to the
internet, prompt the visual search
index, get the data that he needs, the
visual data that he needs, and after a
minute, he will know how to react to
this new scenario he wasn't trained on.
Finishing with that, I have a question
for Sarah and then we're done. Um, do
you think that these parallel lines, me
representing in this case the the robot
as the tech person and you the human
will ever cross?
>> Um, no. And I think that that's the
point to me. They're not parallel lines.
It's a line and a mirror. And a mirror
that's getting very precise, very
convincing, very uh producing very
amazing reflections. But the at the end
of the day, just because it represents a
human, it doesn't mean it will ever
become one.
>> But we'll stay friends, right?
>> But we'll stay friends. [laughter]
>> They'll stay friends as well.
>> Yeah. Yeah. This is my favorite.
>> Thank you for listening, everyone.
>> Thank you.
>> Awesome. Thank you so much.